I did many little things here and there
I did uh three Pilots that went half
Seasons okay uh and then I got a but ABC
didn't want it to let me go Okay so
until they found me Modern Family oh
they knew they had a star they knew that
we have something in this individual
letting her out of our ecosystem would
be foolish let's find and work hard they
gave me a holding deal until they found
Modern Family for me I didn't even
audition the so it was like how long was
it holding you for uh I think it was
like for three years get out of here
yeah and it was fantastic because I mean
it was not fun I mean it was great
because I was getting you know yeah but
I also I wanted to start working I
wanted to find things and they were
waiting for me to find the the right
thing how many things uh were there
things that just weren't working out
um a lot of auditions or just things
that weren't right to fit over the
course of the three years oh yeah
year so it wasn't that fast okay in
those seven years I did a lot you know
many auditions that they told me no and
many you know movies little movies here
and there little Parts uh but the moment
that I did Modern Family was like the
first week
that was it you know what you know what
modern family is like but I compare that
to
um when you talk about the world of
investing right they have these things
that are that are like uh you know
lightning lightning bolts in the bottle
uh things that they feel will only
happen a couple times in a lifetime you
think about Uber
um and the success that Uber had in the
beginning stages well in television it's
the same to be a part of an opportunity
that grows to be a 10-year uh 11 years
11 years 11 years of Television I don't
think that's ever going to happen again
now in television you know because
people want like that now it's fast and
you know they want to move on so fast it
was like it was special for us yeah I
feel like we're in the time of Five
Seasons and that's it right getting past
five seasons is tough I think the world
of the 10 seasons was that was no pun
intended when you're talking about
family a show that Embraces family the
beauty of that you're watching a family
grow yes and the shows throughout the
years that have embraced that not only
if they had success but you felt like
you were a part of the lives of the
characters and the characters dealt with
a lot of real situations in real time
Modern Family did the same thing Steve
Steve Leviton
um a produced on that show phenomenal
guy
um when you were in season one two
did you guys know did you feel like holy
this is we knew from the first
episode when I mean it was like crazy
immediately it was like in I mean the
first award season we were invited to
every award show we were all nominated I
mean it was crazy I never thought I was
going to be able to be part of something
like that and you know to be I used to
watch Ed O'Neill when I was in Colombia
so it was like I couldn't believe it and
I was married to erroneal he was like 20
years older than me I was like it never
I'm like oh my God I remember the first
time that they told me he was going to
be you know my husband I'm like oh my
God I'm going to be stuck with the old
guy in the in the set for hours and it's
gonna be so boring and it was a complete
option it was complete opposite I mean
I'm like what do we have in common you
know I'm from Colombia
I mean we had such a great time him and
and I on the set every day it was
fantastic did you guys like before going
into it because like you said at this
point the network is trying to find
something for you
um they find Modern Family it's gonna be
you it's going to be Ed O'Neill uh
before you got to the place of table
reads Etc did you have to meet Ed a
couple of times no no
holy yeah and the chemistry kicked
off it was it was immediate it was
immediate and you know I was very
worried because my character was you
know a younger woman an immigrant and
with a kid and she it sounded like
completely the gold digger I mean I'm
like oh my God I told my manager he's
like they're going to hate her you know
but then there was something that I did
with the character and that that Ed
helped me do with the character that he
worked and I don't think anyone you
asked thought that Gloria was not really
in love with with uh Jay yeah well it
was great I think that the beauty of
what you were able to do was you were
able to bring a lot of you you weren't
anymore
I was like the first black guy to ever
do the show you always talking like that
about you like you're the first I was I
was the first black guy to do Modern
Family okay and you guys can go look it
up I was a neighbor you guys don't even
know they had a black neighbor it was me
now granted I did one episode because of
my schedule I couldn't do more but that
episode was very funny it was very funny
very very funny
um I mean I don't know if it was because
of you but it was very funny yeah you
were really funny but I don't understand
why I mean really guys I've never heard
you laugh this hard like really it's
never happened and all of a sudden
everybody's got an amazing Funny Bone
around here